David last time we we saw Jesus stop
after very fast-paced action in the
early three chapters of Mark's Gospel he
stopped and just taught for a while in
parables and we had a good conversation
about that where does he go from that
and how did the actions that come after
relate to the words that come in Chapter
four well we said the parables were
strongly about the kingdom which I
suggested was not just a place but the
way in which God establishes God's reign
among human beings God's sovereignty and
I think what we see in the in the end of
chapter 4 certainly through chapter 5 is
Jesus embodying that sovereignty that is
Jesus becomes lord over all kinds of
destructive forces nature in them in the
storm the demoniac we talk about
demoniac here's our full-fledged
demoniac in Chapter five with the with
the man who is so self-destructive and
so isolated from the rest of the people
and then the two women later in chapter
five the girl and the older woman that
this is Jesus saying alright I have now
told you that God is sovereign that
God's sovereignty begins in some ways
like a mustard seed in particular acts
but will spread to the whole world and
now we see kingdom embodied reign
embodied sovereignty embodied as Jesus
becomes the one who claims the world for
God time after time after time so the
words give way to actions that reflect
them and and maybe demonstrate Jesus
relationship to this kingdom has a power
within it as as very close to the
representative of it we don't get
full-fledged
incarnation in Mark's Gospel we don't
have Jesus ever saying hello I'm God
incarnate as we really do in John's
Gospel but we do have Jesus saying
here's here's how I'm gonna talk about
the kingdom of God now I'm gonna do it
and at some point when he starts doing
the kingdom of God the kingdom of God
looks a lot like the kingdom of Jesus -
yeah this I suppose the closest we come
is there are two or three times in this
gospel where he says I am
in response to in chapter 13 in response
to a setting of Apocalypse in the trial
right you know every once in a while I
will say that sort of mysterious term
that sometimes in Greek translations
meaning I am oh yeah I'm echoes that
Exodus 3 passage when Moses says who are
you and God says I am Who I am and it's
in John's Gospel there's no question
when Jesus says I am everybody falls
back into it woo this is very important
in Mark's Gospel they don't fall back
and say woo but we may think that the
other place where it where it seems to
be he makes a strong hint of this is in
that story of the healing of the
paralytic where the where the people
standing by say a truth that they don't
know as a truth which we call irony they
say who can forgive no one can forgive
sins except God alone and they're
suppose they see that shows you Jesus
and we as believers say that's right
watch what this man does this is God in
action yeah and so maybe it's
appropriate that we get for the first
time in this section who is this exactly
exactly in the stilling of the storm
yeah who is this that even the wind and
the waves obey I mean the answer is not
good guy or splendid prophet or
excellent teacher is something more
there's something there I don't think
Mark is anywhere near the Trinity yet
but I think he's very far from here
comes one more good prophet like Elijah
look at what he can do in the early part
of this section
is this fascinating story of gyruss a
synagogue ruler who's by the way the
first positive Jewish leader that we see
in this gospel so we we prick our ears
up because suddenly there's a synagogue
ruler who looks like he's very nicely
sympathetic aircar needs any soliciting
Jesus rather than opposing him and then
in the middle of that the story of a
woman who's got who's hemorrhaging get
talk to me about how that works it's so
compressed yeah yeah well there's the
story as you'll see when you are weeded
over in your text and as as we've seen
is that
the ruler of the scenario comes says my
daughter's dying come help Jesus starts
heading off to gyruss house to help is
interrupted by a woman who's had this
blood flow for 12 years regions out to
touch his garment he stops and it's not
that he intends to healer he has healed
her when she reached out to touch the
garment and he acknowledges what has
happened meanwhile gyrus is standing
over here think wow my daughter is dying
let's move along lady your time will
come but right now let's get home and
Jesus says to gyrus don't be fearful to
be faithful we're heading home and then
goes home and now deliberately performs
a second healing in a way the free he
heals the first one almost accidentally
he heals the second one deliberately but
in both cases he's the healer well a
couple things are going on one thing
that I know you and I have in common
because we've taught this together is we
both think marks a pretty clever
storyteller not a great stylist not a
great Greek writer but a great
storyteller and maybe more of a
storyteller than a writer anyway and
that that one thing you do when you tell
stories is you build suspense so I'm
telling the story of gyruss daughter and
a great way to build suspense is to say
and just as they were heading off to
gyruss house they're interrupted my gosh
is he gonna get there in time you know
Perils of Pauline she's on the track
tied up the train is coming and darn it
if our hero doesn't stop the chat with
the neighbors before he gets there to to
rescue her from the disaster so it's a
great story because then then I'm a
little bit anxious about gyruss daughter
and I'm really anxious about gyruss
daughter and now when he gets there as
mad she's not feeling very well she's
dead so now we're gonna see him do a
real miracle he's got to get her up from
the dead and not just up from her
sickbed great story
alright so that's part of it the other
part of it is Mark has a technique that
that I tell my students is the sandwich
technique which is that in he's always
sticking one thing in the middle of
something else and you understand the
two together so I ham sandwich is a lot
more fun for having both the ham and the
rye bread that especially rye bread by
itself but put a piece of ham and a
interesting interesting mix okay so
woman with the blood flow is an
interesting
ten to this sandwich about gyrus
daughter and I think that's because
there are themes there that mark wants
us to think about what is faith
what is healing what is salvation what
is wholeness what does Kingdom look like
when is enacted what's the difference
between a Jewish ruler who's a
prestigious male and a woman who's got a
hemorrhage who is a probably a despised
female because she can't even come into
the temple because of her her of her
menstrual problems and and saying okay
God is God to all these people
faith counts for all these people Jesus
reaches out to all these people and if
you look at the two stories together
they're more fun than either story by
itself yeah you know we haven't talked
yet about Jesus has reached to people
who are outside the ritual loop right
here we get one right here we go she is
unclean and isolated and I said she
finds her I mean I picture agoraphobia
she finds her way out oh yeah yeah yeah
again like the grain of right of
possible ridicule touches him but the
the I want this for my time management
Jesus stops and listens to her he oh he
doesn't he doesn't just efficiently say
okay that one's taken care of it does be
right it almost says and he stopped and
listened to her whole story yeah which
means he he can be present to her while
something urged very going by very good
we're not just chatting with the
neighbors but he but when he gets to
gyrus he can make it all better
yeah and that's that's the difference
between Jesus and you and me right don't
you yeah we don't if we don't get there
then it really is trouble right yeah
right now it's like but but just to ring
the bell again of the of the inclusion
that's happening here yeah we saw it in
Jesus healing a leper at the end of the
first chapter we saw it in Jesus having
dinner with people who were unsavory
like tax collectors and sinners in in
the second chapter so so it's it's a
good time I think for us to raise that
fact about what this kingdom of God is
looking like and it looks like reaching
out to all kinds of people you wouldn't
normally include and we've just had the
demoniac who is so isolated that he's
isolated himself
he's running out among the tombs in
different ways the demoniac running
among the tombs the woman with a blood
flow and the dead baby the dead young
woman are all cultic li unclean in the
world in which mark writes his gospel in
the world in which Jesus lives and in
each case Jesus just ignores that and
marches out as the sovereign
representative of God to say I'm gonna
claim these people - I'm gonna claim
this world - the storms aren't going to
stop me
cultic uncleanness isn't gonna stop me
blood flow isn't gonna stop me and in a
major wink toward what's gonna happen at
the end of this gospel death isn't gonna
stop me either and the language that's
used when he raises up Jairus daughter
is all resurrection language she she got
resurrected from her bed by the power of
Jesus Christ
and if we're waiting to see what
resurrection is going to look like we've
already got an important clue that
resurrections a claim about him but to
claim about us - and about the people we
love in this little girl and this little
girl in this story that ends with give
her something to eat
yeah right what yes what by the way it's
beautiful yeah she she's feeling so well
it's time for summer yeah so so the the
extension the wider extension of God's
arms to reach more of God's humanity is
is sort of caught in the middle of the
story and and it takes us back to our
inside outside there because now it's
all outside as you were coming in now
we're beginning to worry about whether
the insiders like the disciples are
going to end up out yeah
rocky ground on Peter heading for the
hills but look at these outsiders one by
one they're coming in even gyruss the
images at some level in the first four
chapters the Jewish leaders are on the
outs but here's one here's one who's
come as one who's coming even those guys
kami and is really we're adding my Fame
with him as a whole but it does it does
so in in this section then we've got we
we move from the healing of the demoniac
forward to this healing and on even to
to the we're going to go toward
magnificent feats with bread yeah I know
if part of what's happening is inclusion
and part of it what's happening is a
good story can we talk for a second
about how mark gets there he's got as he
sits down to write what do you picture
mark having when he picks up a gyruss
story yeah in it
how does he start this what does he have
in mind when he gets going yeah he said
he's a good storyteller and you use the
term I think he brings to stories yeah
thereby yes I don't know whether he has
written sources or whether he just got
stories he's gathered through the years
and kind of remembers I my own suspicion
is this is not part of the inner circle
of Jesus from the first time this is the
next generation remembering back the
early church thinks he's currently
remembering Peters stories that may be
true he certainly remembering stories
he's heard through the years no doubt he
remembers some things out of historical
accuracy sometimes I think he remembers
things because these things go together
here are two great stories about faith
here are four great parables about seeds
let's let's do our seed chapter let's do
our faith chapter but then cleverly I
think tying deeds to action and one kind
of faith to another kind of faith and
insiders to outsiders I think he's very
thoughtful about the way in which he is
building us toward the final inclusion
and the final exclusion in chapters 15
and 16 and we're getting there piece by
piece and I I ask partly because there
are a whole lot of stations along the
way with mark a whole lot of different
ways that people have imagined what he's
up to from he's simply stopped
stenograph what Jesus is all the way
over to he's just a collector of Jesus
death when he plops it on a page and
what I think you and I agree that we see
just constantly as mark in mark is a is
a cleverness about bringing these
different traditions together whether
oral or written and putting them in an
order that makes sense as a
characterization of this guy right and I
I'm a golfer and and you can either tear
down the whole earth and start from
scratch when you build a golf course
yeah or you can go and look at that hill
and say how am I going to fit a golf
mark fits the golf course and he takes
things that are already existing and
brings them together in a way that works
architectural II works in our way I
that's one of the things I appreciate
most about him it's not simply creating
from whole cloth he has a lot he has a
lot to write and and some of it is it
could be clumsy but he somehow brings it
together in a in a way that characterize
so the the last question about this
session this this part is when we get
gyruss well-placed
and the woman who is has a hammer yeah
in in the same breath what picture of
that family are we starting to get the
family that we decided finds last time
as the people who do the law of God what
what is Mark doing as we as we continue
to get this influx what's it looking
like
well it's certainly it's looking like it
crosses status barriers that is that
you've got the well-placed of the map so
a place certainly crosses gender
barriers and I think it also you got a a
male who essentially brings his daughter
in and a woman who we design I think it
also I think it also crosses kind of
personality type barriers that you've
got the kind of person who's trying to
figure out what he believes that's
Jarvis how much could I believe as
opposed to fear and the woman who
doesn't actually know what she believes
she just reaches out she needed she
knows she needs help she's heard he
might help and she helps and and in my
years and a pastor it in the using the
password I've been impressed by the fact
that there are people are there because
they've thought it through and this
seems like a reasonable thing to think
about and they're people that just need
help and it's worth a shot
and I kind of I like a family that's got
both those options and I like a gospel
that got those people and that's a great
place to end this time thank you David
thank you